Hi! I'm going to be guiding you through the coding
portions of this course. You're going to start out by
deploying a very simple app, engine application that uses
Endpoint to expose its API to clients. Then you're
going to learn how to define Endpoint functions and how
to call them from the webpage, using JavaScript and
the Google JavaScript Client Library. Then you'll learn about
the Google APIs Explorer, which is a really cool tool.
Not only let's you explore the Google public
APIs, it let's you test out the APIs in
your own application. As you work through this course
you're going to be building up an application called Conference
Central, which let's users schedule and query for
conferences. And you're going to be focusing on implementing the
back-end functionality. Just like on a cooking show, where
they bake the cake for you ahead of time,
and take it out of the oven ready baked,
we've written some of the code for you. Particularly the
boilerplate code, so that you can get straight to work
writing the code that really matters. You're going to start
out by downloading the starting version of Conference Central
for this lesson. And building it up as you go
from lesson to lesson. But, at any point, if you
don't complete the exercises, you don't need to worry because
we provide starting code for you, to help you out, every
stage along the way. Come on, then. Let's go write some code.